OLIVIA MORGAN: Hi, guys.
I'm Olivia Morgan, and
I'm a Looker CE at Google.
And today's session
is going to be
a technical deep dive on
Looker, the enterprise BI
solution for Google Cloud.
To start off with a
lightweight agenda,
we're going to go
over three key pieces.
I want to start with a
Looker architecture overview.
Then we'll touch on
some of the key points
that I'll be going over in
today's technical deep dive.
And we'll spend
most of the session
on the technical
deep dive itself.
And so to kick off the
Looker architecture overview,
I wanted to start
with a statement
that explains the BI landscape
and how we experience data.
And so what this says
is how we experience
data is not what it used to be.
An effective dashboard is
great, but the Looker platform
opens up a world
of possibilities.
And by large and in
part, the Looker platform
opens up these possibilities
because of the way
that we're architected
and because
of the way that we can sit on
top of a SQL database or a SQL
warehouse.
So if you look at this
slide, at the very bottom,
you're going to see a bunch
of different data sources,
things like Google
Ads, Shopify, HubSpot.
And all of those sources are
pushed into your data warehouse
or your data lake.
Now, Looker, as a
BI platform, sits
on top of that database
or data warehouse,
and it speaks SQL to that
database or data warehouse.
And in this case,
in today's demo,
we'll be sitting
on top of BigQuery.
And you can think of
Looker as a powerful API
layer that brings a lot
of different benefits
to the surface
for your end users
and for your technical users.
One of the key pieces
here is that we have
governed metrics in Looker.
So being that we're sitting
right on top of the database,
Looker offers a one-stop shop
version controlled modeling
layer, where you're defining
your business logic,
and you're iterating
on that business logic
in a version controlled way.
We also offer
best-in-class APIs.
So we not only have
API endpoints for data,
we also have API endpoints for
managing your Looker instance,
managing users, groups, or user
attributes for those users.
We also have powerful API
SDKs and embed SDKs, if you're
building custom applications.
Really, a core tenant
of Looker and the way
that it's architected is
that it's in database.
So one analogy I like to
use is, when you put Looker
on top of your database,
it's like chipping your car.
Whatever the engine of
that car is-- in this case,
we're sitting on
top of BigQuery.
Looker is enhancing all of the
features and functionalities
from that database
and will benefit
from any features and
functionality that then
is brought upon that database.
So on top of those
features, of course,
we're version controlled.
That allows for
additional security.
And we are cloud
first, so Looker
does take a
multi-cloud approach,
whether it's GCP
or any other cloud.
And from there,
we're able to operate
in four different
modes, if you're
thinking of the BI
in different ways
that you can serve these
analytics to different end
users.
The first one on the
left is, in the red box,
Modern BI and Analytics.
And that's your traditional
BI data consumption--
your reports, your dashboards.
A use case there might be that
you're building a customer 360
dashboard to view customers
across your channels and media.
The green box,
Integrated Insights,
is more along the lines of
bringing the data to where
your users already consume it.
So if you have sales folks
that operate in Salesforce,
don't ask them to log
into another application.
Use the application to embed
those insights into the tools
they already know and love.
The yellow box,
Data-driven Workflows--
this essentially automates
the first two parts.
The idea is that your
BI tool is going to help
you uncover those insights.
So Looker will help you
uncover, perhaps, customers that
are close to churning, based
off of a customer health score.
And then within the
Looker application,
you can use that application
to actually trigger
the action you'd like to take--
maybe based off of a low
customer health score,
we're sending emails
to those customers.
And then the last one,
Custom Applications--
a custom application
you can spin up
in any way, shape, or form.
A large reason why Looker opens
this up in such a powerful way
is because, not only
we're in-database,
but we do have a
powerful suite of APIs.
So when you have a version
controlled and governed layer
to pull metrics
from, you can create
a slew of custom applications.
You can use our APIs to render
visualizations or data points
to make any sort of custom
workflow you can dream up.
Now, for the demo
today, I wanted
to go over a few key
points of the pieces
that I wanted to touch on.
I really want to highlight
the fact that this instance is
hosted on GCP, and
we are going to be
sitting on top of BigQuery.
So what you'll see
within the demo
is that we're going
to use Google Cloud
Functions and the search API
for things like product image
searches.
You'll notice that we have BQML
laced within our Looker models
for item sales and
stock forecasting.
We're also going
to use the BigQuery
weather public data set.
So you'll see
examples where we can
start to interact
with public data sets
to make the analysis richer.
We're also leveraging
nested tables
for things like faster
performance on transaction
analysis, in this case.
And then lastly,
we're able to utilize
faster and more
efficient queries
with BI engine and Looker's
aggregate awareness.
So now I'd like to transition
into the technical deep dive,
where I can show you Looker
on top of GCP and BigQuery.
In the Looker demonstration,
we are hosted on GCP,
and we're sitting on top
of a BigQuery database.
We're working off of
a retail data set.
And so our goal with our models
and view files and our LookML
is to be able to support
end user experiences,
like the merchandising
VP or regional VP logging
in to look at performance.
Most of our time today
is going to be spent here
in this Develop tab.
But what we'll do is we'll
start in the Admin tab
by creating a
database connection.
So once that database
connection is created,
the Develop tab is where we
build our Looker Symantec
model, or the LookML.
For those of us that are
developing in LookML,
we're exposing those models to
end users via this Explore tab.
And for those end
users, whatever
they're building
in this Explore tab
then populates the Browse
tab, which then also populates
these boards and
folders for end users.
Now, starting in
the Admin panel,
I want to take you all to
our database connections
and establish a
database connection.
And we'll open
this in a new tab.
Now, when you're establishing
a database connection,
you can go ahead and add the
new connection button up here
at the top.
For our demo, we already
have a connection
established with Looker data.
So I'm going to go ahead and
edit this connection so we
can see how this is set up.
So we have our Looker
data connection.
The dialect we are connected
to, as I mentioned, is BigQuery.
But if I open up
this panel, you can
see all of the
different dialects--
or a variety of the
that Looker connects to.
On the Google front, we've got
Legacy, Standard, PostgreSQL--
and also Cloud SQL
and Cloud Spanner.
Once we've selected
the dialect, you
can select the project
name and data set name
that you're pointing Looker to.
But let's say your
use case calls
for a little bit more dynamism.
You can also use user
attributes in Looker
to dynamically set a value
for a user or a group,
if you're pointing them to
separate project names or data
sets.
Now, within Google, many
of you might use OAuth.
And so Looker does
integrate with OAuth.
And we can use a OAuth
for IM integration.
We support service accounts.
So that's another
way that you can
support authentication
and connection
settings within Looker.
Add your usernames
and your passwords.
And then down here
at the bottom,
another interesting feature here
is that max billing gigabyte.
So if you wanted to set
a maximum number of bytes
billed allowed on a
single BigQuery query,
you could do that.
And then similar to those host
and ports up there at the top,
if we wanted to dynamically set
this value for users or groups,
we could.
Now that the connection's been
established, what we need to do
is we need to create
a LookML project.
Now, the LookML
projects in Looker
are essentially a
house that contains
all of your model
and your view files.
Before we move into that
project, what we'll want to do
is jump into development mode.
And this allows
me, as a developer,
to start editing or
creating my own projects.
So to walk you guys
through the flow,
I'm going to click on
Manage LookML Projects,
and I'll show you how
to create a new project.
Up in the right-hand
corner, we'll
select New LookML Project.
And what we'll do is
we can give our project
a name, a starting
point, and a connection.
So we can name the project
whatever we'd like.
The starting point
really depends
on how you would like
to begin building
the logic for your analysis.
So in many cases, folks
will generate a model
from a database schema.
In this case, Looker
scans the database
and brings back or automatically
generates the models
in the view files.
We can select generate from SQL,
clone a public Git repository--
which this demo is based
off of one of our blocks.
So if you decided to point
Looker to one of our public Git
repos that we have hosted
for a particular source
or analytic analysis,
we can point Looker
to that repository, and it will
automatically generate or pull
those files for us as well.
Now, in our case, we already
have a project defined.
So in the Development
tab, I want
to navigate you guys
to the retail demo.
And within the
retail data set, what
you'll see here in the
upper left-hand corner is,
we are version controlled.
So when I jumped into
development mode,
I essentially put myself
into my own code branch.
We have look LookML validation
here on the left side
as well before you push
changes to production.
But the main components
I want to focus on here
are models and views.
So you'll see we have a model
folder and a view folder that
contains a variety
of different views.
For Looker, a model file points
to a database connection.
So here, we've pointed it to
our Looker data connection.
And within this connection,
what the file tells
Looker is how to think about
the schema of that database.
And so in this case, we
have our transactions table
or transaction view file right
after an explore parameter.
Now, the file name that comes
after the explore parameter
populates the from
clause in the SQL query.
And so the way we read
this is from transactions,
join transaction line items,
join customers, join customer
facts, and so on and so forth.
When we're establishing
join relationships,
we use the relationship
parameter and the SQL parameter
to help Looker protect
against symmetric aggregates.
So once we define
these parameters,
Looker will automatically
detect over-counting,
and it will adjust to protect
from any symmetric aggregates.
Now, in this case, we
have a transactions table,
and we have a
transaction line items.
This is nested data
within BigQuery.
And so Looker works
seamlessly with nested data.
All we have to do in
the SQL parameter,
or what Looker will do when it
detects a nested field, is it
will do a left join unnest--
in this case, on our
line items table--
so that we can start to
use this for analysis
and unpack that data.
Now, another important thing
here is our always filter.
In Looker, you can
use always filter
to apply a filter restriction
on this explore section,
so that when users are running
queries, they're protected,
A, against running large
historical queries, but B,
that we are pointing them
to a BigQuery partition.
So if we actually go
to the Explore section
and we type in our retail,
our transaction detail
explore right here,
you'll notice, at the top,
we have a filter for
transaction date.
And it is required.
So no matter what I pull-- if I
go here to the left-hand side,
and I decide to
pull channel name,
that SQL parameter
will always have
a where clause pointing us
to either the partition time
or the partition in BigQuery.
Now, going back to
our model file--
if our model is where we point
to the database connection
and we explain to
Looker the schema,
the view files are how
we define the tables.
Now, you'll notice, when
we spun up the project,
Looker will automatically
create a list of views for us.
Let's say there are views
that I would like to add.
There's two different
ways that we can
start to add additional files.
I can go ahead and
create another model,
if I'd like to point to
another database connection.
Or I can create views from
table or create views outright.
If I create a view from table,
what that workflow looks like,
as I'm iterating in
my project, Looker
will bring you to
a schema viewer
where I can simply
select a schema.
I can select a table.
Maybe I'm selecting
my Zillow data here.
And at the bottom, I
can bring these files
or create views, which will
create a new view file here
in my project.
Now, for the view files in
this demonstration today,
we have a few base views and a
few examples of derived tables
or derived views in Looker.
So if I open up
my views dropdown,
a couple of the core
tables that we have here
are things like our transactions
table, our store dimension
table, our customer
Dim, our product Dim.
If I look at our base
transactions table,
you can see the view name
and the SQL table name,
which points us to that table
sitting in the database,
the schema dot table name.
And every column coming
from the database
is now its own dimension.
Now, you'll notice,
underneath each dimension,
we have a couple
different parameters.
In this case, we've
got a type number.
This is the primary key.
And in the SQL parameter,
it's pointing Looker
to table dot transaction ID.
Now, this table is injecting
that single table name,
retail demo dot transaction
detail dot transaction ID.
Now, this injection
becomes very important
when we are deriving
new fields in Looker.
So if we come down here
to our derived dimensions,
you'll notice a couple
different examples.
One example is a
dimension group.
So we've got since first
customer transaction.
What we're doing is we've
derived a new field.
In this case, it's a mentioned
group of type duration.
And we've given
Looker a SQL start
and a SQL end date to derive the
months since our customer first
transacted.
Now, why this is
significant is, instead
of pointing to a table dot
column name, a field that
exists in the database, I'm
pointing us to another field
in order to derive a new field.
And so SQL is a
declarative language,
but it doesn't always
lend itself well
to the benefits of
object-oriented programming.
And so this is an example
where LookML really
brings in those values of
object oriented programming,
in the sense of reusability
and extensibility.
So when I continue
to scroll down here,
and I'm looking at my measures--
number of transactions,
number of customers--
I can start to pull counts,
and sums, and averages
on particular fields that are
coming from the Looker data
model, customer
ID, and store ID.
Or we can become a little more
complex with our aggregations
by notating a measure
of type number
and actually doing
the aggregation
or doing the calculation
in the SQL itself.
Now, to make it really
rich for end users,
you'll notice on all of these
measures we have these drill
detail fields.
These drill details
will specify a list
of fields that is pulled
back when a user clicks
on that aggregation.
And so you'll see drill
details defined up here.
So if a user defines or
clicks on one of those metrics
or measures, Looker is going
to uncover the date, the store
name, the product
area, the product name
so that the user can
see the real level
detail related to that metric.
Now, if our base
transaction table
is an example of a core table
coming from our database
connection, a couple of examples
of derive tables in Looker
are our customer facts or
our customer transaction
sequence table.
So if we look at the
customer facts table,
what you'll quickly notice
is we have the view name,
but instead in the
SQL table name,
we've invoked a derived table.
And under the derived
table, it allows
you to drop in a simple SQL
statement or a complex SQL
statement so that you can start
to derive or prototype schema
changes.
What's powerful
about this is you
don't need to physically copy
the data on the database side
or create a fact table on
the database side in order
for Looker to
leverage or for you
to prototype what type of
analysis this would give you.
You can simply create
that analysis in Looker.
And if you'd like
to speed it up,
we can start to persist
these pieces of data.
So you'll notice here we've
got data group triggers.
So this derived table is
governed by a caching policy.
That's a daily caching policy.
And a shortcut in Looker, if
I hold down the Option key,
I'll get this plus button.
I can click on that
data group trigger
and Looker will navigate me
to where that's been defined.
You'll notice it took me back to
my retail block modeling file,
where our data groups
have been defined.
In this case, our
daily data group
is triggered by a
select current date.
And the contingency
here is a max cache age.
Why this is really powerful is,
if we want to sync Looker up
with your data
pipeline-- let's say
we want to sync Looker
with your ETL processes,
we can define a SQL
trigger that detects
changes in your ETL files.
So maybe when a new ETL
process is completed,
we can signify a rebuild
of that derived table,
or a re-caching of that table.
So going back to the
customer facts table,
you'll also notice
a few pieces here--
things like partition
keys and cluster keys.
Now, when Looker is sitting
on top of a database,
BigQuery or otherwise,
it is enhancing what
is coming from the database.
So given that we can
optimize BigQuery
by utilizing partition
keys and cluster keys,
Looker inherently has parameters
that we can use to leverage
or define these partition keys
and cluster keys for folks that
are defining derive tables.
Now, for the derived table, we
can create this derived table
by, instead of creating
view from table,
creating a view outright.
The other way we
can do it is we can
use Looker to generate
the derived table for us.
So a really powerful
work flow in Looker
is to use the Explore section
to generate a SQL query.
Now, for the end user, it will
always look like a result set.
But for the more
technical developer,
that SQL query is something that
you can use for your projects
and models.
So let's say this represented
a derived table that I would
like to use for a project.
I can open in SQL
runner down here
in the bottom right-hand corner.
And Looker will move my
query back to the SQL runner.
SQL runner can be navigated to
here in our development tab.
But once that query
is run, and I'll just
take a look at the
results set here,
I can go into the upper
right-hand corner,
and I can derived table LookML.
So I can already
derive that table
and create the view
file for myself.
You'll see that every column
coming from that view file
or coming from that
SQL query has now been
its own measure in dimension.
And all I need to do is
add it back to my project.
So you can use Looker to
expedite the SQL writing
process for you.
Even if you're writing
a derived table
or a native derived
table, you can
use Looker to help
you generate that SQL
and generate that view file.
Now, aside from the
customer facts table,
we also have examples of BQML
being utilized in Looker.
Our stock forecasting tables and
our customer clustering tables
are two examples here.
So if we start with the
stock forecasting table,
you'll notice a little different
flavor of a derived table.
Instead of a SQL
specific derived table,
we're using something called a
native derived table in Looker.
Why native drive
derived tables are
powerful is, as you will notice,
they're not dialect specific.
So LookML, as a modeling layer,
it is a SQL translation layer.
The value there is that with any
point and click of an end user,
Looker is translating
those clicks
into optimize SQL
for whatever database
we're sitting on top of.
So in the case of
native derived tables,
given that these are
not dialect specific,
it makes it really easy if I'm
going through a data warehouse
modernization project,
or I'm moving back ends
and using Looker
as the front end
to help me with that migration.
I can simply swap out the
connection name in my model
file, and I can reuse
these derived tables.
I don't need to rewrite them
into a different dialect.
So the stock forecasting
shows a nice example of that.
Within the stock forecasting
view file-- and forgive me
for my scrolling.
I'm going to have to scroll
down to the bottom here--
we'll be able to see
examples of our BQML model.
So with the BQML model
here, we did feed
in about 200 inputs, just
from our transactions table.
And ultimately,
what we're doing is
we're using BQML
linear regression
to forecast sales by store,
by item, and by week.
And so if we get down
here to the regression,
you can see here that we're
using our SQL create statement
on this derived table
to create or replace
the name of that derived table--
and using linear
regression here.
Now, they're defined
in our LookML model,
so if I want to change
our linear regression
or iterate on some
of these BQML models,
we can easily iterate
on those models,
validate them, and test
them on the front end.
You'll also notice down
here that we're also
doing some sort of prediction on
our stock forecasting as well.
Now, for customer
clustering, this
is a really good example
of using clustering
to create customer segments.
So again, we have our customer
clustering input up here
at the top, where
we're inputting
a native derived table
coming from Looker.
And then we can define
the clustering model here
with k-means clustering.
And we've defined
the clusters of four.
And so with those clusters,
then on the front end,
we can use our customers
explore to start
to explore those different
customer segments,
whether they are
millennials, Gen Xers--
whether they're
net new customers.
And you'll see down
here at the bottom
that we also have a customer
clustering prediction.
And so what this is doing is--
this is out of the
box with our block
to help cluster our
customers into those buckets,
whether they're millennials,
retirees, or Gen Xers.
Again, this can
be used right out
of the box with
this retail block.
Or, if you'd like to
iterate on this model
or customize it in any way,
shape or form, you can.
Now, the last piece
I wanted to touch on
before we moved into
the Explore section
was our public data sets
that we're working with.
So if we look at our store
weather table here in Looker,
this is an example where
we're using the BigQuery
global daily weather
public data set
to map a retailer stores to
the nearest weather stations.
We want to get each store's
daily weather out of the box.
And so you can see the
BigQuery public data
set being leveraged here for all
different years and the mapping
that's happening on Looker.
So I do like to describe
the LookML model in Looker
as kind of a lightweight
transformation layer.
So you can see that some of
these models are very complex.
You can host a lot
of complex logic.
But more importantly,
I'm able to leverage,
really, any function
or functionality
that is coming from BigQuery
or GCP to make this really rich
for our end users.
Now, with all of those pieces--
and I'll go ahead
and stay logged in--
we want to navigate to
the explorers, right?
So all of the work we've
done with our store-- weather
views, all of our transaction
and our clustering.
What we've done is we've
gone into our model file.
And we've defined different
explores-- transaction
detail, customer-- and we
have all of the joins defined.
And so for myself as an end
user, what's really easy to do
is to now move into
the Explore section
and build any analysis
that I'd like.
So if we go ahead into
the Explore section,
I'm going to navigate back
to our transaction detail.
And I'm actually going to
jump out of development mode.
And so now, on my
transaction detail explorer,
on the left-hand side,
everything that was joined
are now tables that I
can point and click from.
So if I look at our
transactions table,
I can see I can
pivot, filter, or add
some sort of a custom measure.
If I'm a developer, I can move
backwards into the LookML.
This is really
important, that Looker
allows you to move
seamlessly from the front end
to the back end.
The architecture
being simplified
as it is, given that all of your
metrics are governed under one
develop tab--
it's very easy to understand,
not only how things
are defined, but
to update metrics
and to update dimensions
for end users,
to deliver the analysis
that they want.
Now, along with
those dimensions,
there are my dimension groups
with all of my type time.
And down here at the bottom in
orange are all of my measures.
Now, we do have
our access filter
up here at the top, or our
filter for our partitions
up here at the top.
And so let's say I want to
do a year over year sample.
Let's say I would like to
look at data for the past four
years.
So I'd like to do a year over
year for the past four years.
I can go ahead and add my
month number into the analysis.
I might want to look at my
total sales year over year.
And I will pivot that
by my year bucket.
And we can give that a run.
Now, you might have noticed in
the upper right-hand corner,
as I'm querying,
Looker will tell you
whether it's pulling from cache.
Or it will tell you
how large the results
set-- it will predict the size
of the query before you run it.
Now, when it returns
a visualization,
I've got my visualization,
along with the data table.
I can go ahead and start to play
with how this is visualized.
So let's say I want to
not plot null values.
And I'd like to add an outline
to my year over year analysis.
Again, this is all
being generated off
of that core model.
So there are all of those
timezone conversions,
the filters that I've added.
In our SQL statement
for the end user,
it's a simplified results set.
As soon as it's
rendered, I can drill.
If I want to look at all
354k on this data point,
Looker will also automatically
handle time hierarchies.
So if I want to continue to
drill down into different time
hierarchies here, I can.
But to support that
data analysis workflow,
if I want to then add
this back to my dashboard
or save it as a report, I can.
I can also save and start
to schedule this out.
So when we're talking
about integrated insights
or data driven
workflows, what I can do
is I can set those data driven
workflows here in the Explorer
and start to push those out
to different users or groups--
or set those workflows
in motion that
are going to be most
beneficial to me.
Now, if I go to save this
back to my dashboard,
I'll go into my folder here.
And we can save it back
to our group overview
that we started on.
And I'm going to call
this year over year sales.
Now, we can head back to the
group overview dashboard.
And this is where
the end users are
going to come to consume all of
the stock forecasting, customer
clustering, the public
data sets that we've
laced into this demo.
But now it's in easy
to consume format.
It's visual.
I can see my basket size.
If I'm a VP of retail,
I can see the percent
of customers that are
transacting, from my loyalty
customers.
I can see geographically
where my stores are located.
And if I want to dig into
any sort of top movers,
I can look at my change by
store and change by category.
And I can easily start
to take action on these.
So now if I want to integrate
with Google App Engine
and create a text
or a call function
to contact that
store manager, we
can send a text quickly
to that store manager.
I can go ahead and grab the
link that would hit their inbox.
And when I open
that link, I'll be
taken to a store deep dive
that's already been updated
for my Los Angeles store.
And so I can easily
start to take a look
at why this store might be
under-performing-- and then
look at different
examples of that work
we did on the back
end and how it's
displaying on the front end.
So if we're looking at
our peer store comparison,
I can see how I'm doing
versus my peer stores.
I can look at the
weather trends to see
if my transactions
decreasing has anything
to do with the weather.
And then when we get down
to stock forecasting here,
I can easily see how
much of a product
I have in stock versus
what's forecasted
and what the stock
difference might be.
And then if I need to take
action on any of these pieces,
I can go ahead and
explore from here
and move backwards into
the report building
interface, where I can
start to alert when my stock
difference, in
this case, might be
greater than or equal
to a particular value.
And of course, this is just
the BI and analytics workflow.
So if we want to
get more advanced,
certainly, this could
become an iframe
that I then embed into
a custom application.
Any of these points become API
endpoints or query endpoints
that I can pull into a custom
application or custom workflow.
But that's the end of my
technical deep dive on Looker.
I hope that it was informative,
and thanks so much for joining.